[Music]
material samples brought back from
objects in space can shed light on
billions of years of our solar system's
history including details about the
origin of life here on earth
a piece of an asteroid is a piece of the
earliest beginnings of the solar system
4.6 billion years ago when our solar
system formed initially there was just
gas and dust swirling around and that
coalesced
into planetesimals and those things
crashed into each other and got bigger
and some became planets and those that
did not
remain as asteroids and they're like
little snapshots of earth's beginnings
but picking up rocks from the surface of
an asteroid or planetary satellite isn't
as easy as it sounds
it requires voyages of millions of miles
to bodies that have never been seen up
close
probes need to land on surfaces with
weak gravitational pulls where the
surface terrain is completely unknown
gather samples and then make the long
trip back
and while behemoths like nasa and spacex
grab headlines it's a relatively young
space agency
the japan aerospace exploration agency
better known as jaxa that is taking the
giant leap necessary to bring the
mysteries of space back down to earth
[Music]
if we want to find out about the origin
of our solar system or the origin of
life itself
we need to study materials that were
around 4.6 billion years ago when the
solar system was born
meteorites actually fit that bill and
luckily the earth is lousy with them
meteorites make impacts with our planet
all the time there's just one problem
itself was officially founded in 2003
when three different national space
agencies were merged into one
prior agencies in japan had excelled in
infrared and x-ray astronomy and the
design and launch of communications
satellites and rockets
jaxa continued those efforts as it began
devoting money and research into sample
return
with the need for relatively untouched
materials from space clear planning for
the world's first sample return from an
asteroid began in 1995.
on may 9 2003 the robotic spacecraft
hayabusa meaning falcon in english
launched
with its path set for the asteroid
itakawa a near-earth asteroid located
between mars and earth
using its four ion engines for the one
million two hundred thousand mile plus
journey hayabusa made contact with
itakawa more than two years after its
launch in september of 2005.
that is a special challenge these
asteroids are not as large as planets
and they don't have
the gravity to allow you to just land so
you have to figure out how to land and
stick there and then have your your
instrument your drill or your collector
operate in those conditions
not everything went according to plan
weeks were spent trying and failing to
launch hayabusa's designated probe and
there was a fuel leak from its chemical
engine part of the difficulty with the
hayabusa mission was with the size of
itakawa itself only 1100 feet in
diameter its gravitational pull is weak
so hayabusa had to maintain heliocentric
orbit meaning the craft would track the
asteroid's path around the sun
in addition the distance from earth
required hayabusa to be fully autonomous
thanks to the communication delay
[Music]
the probe was finally able to touch down
and attempt a sample retrieval on
itakawa for 30 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as hayabusa returned no one knew whether
the sample collection had been a success
or not but upon its arrival to earth in
june of 2010 less than one milligram of
dust from itakawa was discovered in its
collection module a truly tiny specimen
but nevertheless the first successful
asteroid sample return in history
one of the conclusions was that the
meteorite achikawa that was studied was
consistent with stony meteorites that we
have found on the earth but we couldn't
really conclude that until we could get
an actual sample from
the asteroid bring it back and make a
direct comparison
second
jaxa would expand on this flawed but
successful mission with the launch of
hayabusa 2 to the asteroid yugu in 2014.
the second asteroid sample retrieval
mission was notable not only for its
more advanced machinery and distance of
9 million miles but for its destination
unlike itakawa's inert collection of
boulder-sized rocks yugu is carbonaceous
meaning it contains some of the solar
system's most pristine untouched
materials minerals ice and organic
materials
the carbonaceous
ones are of great
interest to us especially in this recent
hayabusa2 mission because they contain
remnant organic matter and also water
that may have been
the source of organic matter to evolve
life in the source of water for the
oceans on earth
after its approach to yugu hayabusa 2
deployed a series of three small rovers
that due to the asteroid's low gravity
made a series of hops rather than roll
on wheels to survey its surface
in order to retrieve a subsurface sample
free from the weathering of space the
craft needed to fire a projectile into
the surface of the asteroid and in
another first created a man-made crater
in yugo
hayabusa 2 was then able to descend and
conduct subsurface sampling from the
site of the blast
unlike the first mission the second was
able to collect more than five grams of
material from the surface of yuku now
the largest asteroid sample ever
recovered
originally we expected to have the
samples greater than 0.1 gram but ended
up with the 4.5 grams which is more than
50 times of the glams
the next surprise was that there is the
infrared microscope found water bearing
minerals
the i abused it ii mission sampling
ryugu
has yet to yield information
because the samples came back in 2020
they've been distributed to labs all
over the world and we'll soon get
information from them on the origin of
water potentially from meteorites as
well as the nature of carbonaceous
material
jax's next sample return mission is set
to be its most ambitious and
illuminating yet and it's to an area of
the solar system that's particularly
popular at the moment the mmx or martian
moons exploration mission is slated to
visit two of mars's moons phobos and
deimos with a launch planned for 2024
mmx will visit and survey both moons
with the hope of collecting a sample
from phobos in mid-2025 and a return to
earth in 2029
mmx seeks to find whether phobos and
deimos are asteroids that became caught
in mars orbit long ago or if there were
fragments that coalesced after a major
impact with the red planet as scientists
more often suspect
there are also implications for the
origins of life in our solar system
[Music]
mmx will be humanity's first opportunity
at bringing back samples from other
planetary systems and jaxa hopes that
the round-trip visit will reveal
important information that can be used
on future manned missions to the martian
sphere including whether phobos can be
used as an orbital base
[Music]
on mmx part of the sampling will be done
with the help of us-based honeybee
robotics
meet planetvac
the planetary vacuum sucks up regolith
another name for the dirt lying on top
of the bedrock of space bodies and
collects it to either be analyzed by
onboard tools or stored away for return
to earth
the planetvac takes the place of a leg
on a lander and uses compressed gas
that's usually already on board the
craft to pressurize fuel tanks
mmx is still currently in the
development stage and jaxa says the cost
will be around 419 million dollars
if all goes according to plan jaxa can
further cement its track record as the
world's premier experts at sample return
jax's sample return missions will over
the coming decades help prepare other
space agencies for manned missions to
various types of environments in space
and as research continues on the samples
already brought back help to solve some
of the mysteries that still exist about
the formation of life on earth
the world over smaller space agencies
have found crucial niches that don't
require the massive funding of nasa blue
origin or spacex
in this way jaxa is more than holding
their own with our worlds space
heavyweights
you